whether it's stories of bodies littering
the streets obama in nigeria residents
of gaza trying to rebuild their lives
following israeli airstrikes or the is
islamic state's reign of terror across
syria and iraq the unfolding horrors are
hard to digest with so many crises how
best can europe help the aid depends on
the problems in gaza we heard
schools hospitals medical equipment
in the ebola crisis in west africa is
getting nurses on the ground getting
doctors on the ground and making sure we
can properly deal with the disease so
each crisis has a different response but
it's very much needs led we just need to
make sure we make the money available
data suggests that gdp has remained
stable in the euro area compared
to the first quarter of 2014
and that it has increased by 0.7
percentage points compared to the same
period
in 2013
so good news for europe as mr deiser
bloom made his first appearance before
the economic and monetary affairs
committee since the summer
today's discussion with mep's focus on
fine-tuning existing monetary policy
whilst at the same time supporting
growth
but for some they were ready to not only
offer their hand but a little advice to
the president of the eurogroup he
basically said the reforms are underway
growth is coming back sorry to say that
clearly
the signs of hope we had before the
summer they have evaporated we need
sustainable investment and for this to
finance we need taxation to be just and
to close the tax havens and end
corporate tax competition in europe
1900 that's a staggering statistic for
the number of people that have died
since the outbreak of ebola there's no
vaccine or cure and with the epidemic
spreading fast getting the outbreak
under control is vital
in africa
organizations or performing person
epidemia